hello everyone thank you for attending
this webinar and we're going to talk
about tiny power sensors and about ships
and their biggest potential in health
care so there are two ways to
rationalize why this is a very important
topic on firstly it's a application
driven and in us we know that health
care costs is exploding and population
is aging rapidly and that's true for
many advanced countries shown here and
in the u.s. is kind of a out a liar
because we spend more money per capita
than any other country in the world and
the total healthcare spending is 2.25
trained dollars in 20 13 and we can
anticipate that this trend will also
show up similar trends will show up in
developing countries as those countries
also become more advanced and people
live longer and longer and when you look
at the health care spending versus age
you find that the spending after 50
years old odd is a much more than when
you're younger and that's quite a normal
because we really don't get sick very
often when you are in twenties in the
30s but the UM this curve is the radical
for us is actually quite a alarming and
this means we're spending money where
it's not a most efficient and
we anticipated that in the future we can
spend more money early to keep people
more healthy with better life style and
have more technologists to be well and
then we can actually reduce the spending
burden in later stages of life so that's
where technologists will come in on
regardless soft applications we are
inventing many technologies in both pal
biotechnology medical technology and
information technologies many many other
fields and here I just list a few
nanosensors genome sequencing we're both
like SmartWatch fit a bit jawbone etc
and on this chart shows the cost of
sequencing a human genome versus a year
and the purple curve is a famous Moore's
law in semiconductor industry and the
Green Line shows a cost per genome
sequenced and you can see initially it's
dropping just like most law but in
recent decades that cause the whole
genome has dropped precipitously and now
we are at about one thousand dollars and
that opens a lot of application avenues
in healthcare and there many other such
inventions and these once properly
connected to a right type of application
it will be game changes in health care
arena
so from this slide the forward I will
show you a few examples of tiny chips
which can have greater person n chose
and some of which has already made big
changes in health care the first example
is a real time in vivo biosensors
developed by Professor console on who is
just the joining Stanford faculty he
previously work at UC Santa popular and
here G graduated from Stanford mmm
electro engineering department and so
it's a homecoming for him as temple we
are very pleased to have him back on
board and his group has developed this
amazing in vivo biosensors shown here in
B that's basically a schematic of the
sensor and it's basically a electrical
chemical power sensor and the electrode
is typically gold and on this code we
immobilize optima and this optimum is
labeled with a chemical in the hand and
this chemical when sees certain
molecules in solution they will go
through chemical reaction and produce
electrons and if this optima is just
like shown in the last these electrons
will basically dissipated in the
solution and a more way now if there are
certain molecules in the solution
bueller it's a molecule of interest
often called analyte and this optimal
will then fold and at the end of the top
dollar this blue dot will
very close to the electrode now if you
induce the electrochemical reaction
again these electrons will be very close
to the electrode and they will be picked
up by the electrode so now you have a
much more pronounced electro signal
detected so that means the electro
signal now will be about one-to-one
correlation to the concentration of
green analyte here and that's a basic
principle of this real-time in vivo
thousands and why is this technology
game-changing um the because dr. seuss
group has made this sense are so small
they can implement it into a animal
right now in in future in human and as
we know that we take a lot of medicines
when we get sick and different people
will have different those to see
efficacy and right now doctors don't
know which person have the best those to
use and if you use too much medicine
often times they have toxicity okay so
so there's a window of that's those
between efficacy and toxicity and not
vary from person to person so with this
power sensor you can actually measure
that those of drug inside the body
circulating in real time and in this
Science Translational Medicine paper
published on you will find that
I thought those group has managed to
measure doxorubicin a common chemo
therapy drug for cancer and that they
can reliably monitor that those change
of that pops loops and inside body
another example of tiny bow chips is
from my own group shown in the middle
here is a device called mega sister or
magnetic sifter they are fashioned out
of silicon substrate with circum nitrile
membrane and we hatch small pores into
the certain nitro in the membrane and
after that we coated the membrane with
magnetic films if you apply maenette
field to this device the main em film
will be magnetized and generator very
strong may not feel the gradient so if
there are any small magnetic objects on
talking through they will be captured on
this device um so what's their use well
they are very powerful divide a tool for
capturing so called a circulating tumor
cell also called CTCs commonly in the
field as you know when a patient get a
cancer the yearly originating in one
place so it is a lung cancer it's your
originating non but it lung cancer
itself does not kill a patient yearly
the cancer will grow in a venturi it
will metastasize and many other
secondary cancers will pop up everywhere
and then the person will not be able to
handle it anymore and
some give way to the cancer and that's
the tragic and alpha the disease
progression now the key to diagnose
cancer and also to cure cancer in the
future is to study CTCs but the CDC's is
very rare in blood circulation for one
building healthy normal cells
circulating blood vessel there's about
12 hundred CTCs ok so it's truly
searching a needle in a haystack when
you try to enrich and capture city sees
so this is a tube of blood sample and we
take this from the hospital and then mix
this blood sample with mainly
nanoparticles so the green cells are
circulating tumor cells and that they
are labeled with a black dot so now they
may netobjects all the other thoughts
red and gray healthy cells like white
blood cell red blood cells etc so you
take a little mixture pass this device
and all the unlabeled healthy cells and
other matrix of components in the blood
will pass through and the labored cdc's
will be captured after that we turn off
the main airfield now we can release
Manor labeled serpentine tumor cells and
then we pass to a device koda nano well
this is made hot play by microfluidic
technology and each well we'll have one
or no CTCs and then we do to chipper
wide
reverse transcription-polymerase chain
reaction also called rt-pcr basically we
amplify RNA molecules in each well and
from that we can study mutations
associates CDC's and various gene
expression pattern in the cells so from
those signals we can identify CDC's
further and we can study their mutation
status and this can be used for cancer
diagnosis and also to inform dr. what
drugs to use for a particular patient
now this is a slider from Google and
Google X is a tip has a vision to
develop so called a wearable disease
diagnostic on the idea is that you have
a welder device on your SmartWatch a
smarter band and those smart bands have
a device optical sensor for example to
see objects flowing in your bloodstream
and one vision is that if we say wanted
to detect circus in tumor cells in blood
in the last slide we have to draw the
blood and takes outside of the body to
do so could in virtual diagnosis in this
case we don't take any blood other body
instead we inject nanoparticles or nano
labels into the bloodstream the
biocompatible so they will not cause
harm to your body but they will latch on
to circulating tumor cells now this
circle leading to my body a tumor cells
labeled by these orange nano labels and
they were emitted certain
signals the optical signals or other
signals and they will be picked up by
the smart band and now without the blood
draw without going to hospital you may
get an early warning of cancer on set
and this will be the future technology
and I hope to hear good news from google
hexa other parties in the future about
this fascinating vision in my own group
we are also working on mobile power
sensors in this case we use a man-eater
nanosensor which is buried in the bottom
of this nano well and this is a tiny PCB
board so we can talk to the sensor as
the sensor detected analytes you know I
don't have time to go over the details
of this sensor you can certainly look up
my papers in the internet but it here is
a very quick a demo to show that with
this sensor we can detect antibodies
against the hepatitis B so to analyze
whether you're protected against
hepatitis B virus or not ok so this is a
real-time video and it's sped up at a
son to certain person pushing so the
whole thing in real time lost about 15
minutes but it's a fast afforded to to
allow you to see the whole process and
here my student is doing a finger prick
to draw a tiny drop of blood and mix
with some buffer solution and then
loaded to this reader station and the
reader station is completely controlled
by that smartphone and the sensor is
already inserted from the side here
now that s is finished the tow test
itself took about 10 minutes and the
test results now is emailed to the
medical record of your primary care and
this is a test result for 10 volunteers
and each bar assoc with the
concentration of antibody against
hepatitis be measured and you can see
that for volunteer 16 and eight their
antibody level is very low so by the
prieto standard these people these
people are unprotected so if they have
exposure to hepatitis B virus they may
become sick now for other volunteers
they have high level of antibody against
the hepatitis B and they will have very
low probability being infected by this
virus and I happen to be one of the
volunteers and of all the three
unprotect ones and I'm hoping to see my
dog to get a boost shot off and her body
and I mean vaccine to get on my end up
at a level up so I can be safely
traveling in East Asia and Africa those
are areas at high prevalence of
hepatitis B we also keep track of many
other emerging power sensors in other
university and companies another example
here is a opto maenette about sensor
from philips which is specifically
designed for application at the point of
care and this
when a video from Phil's website I'm
obviously not a paid out of it endorser
for Phillips this is shown to you just
to illustrate the many exciting tiny
chips out there and this process is
exciting to me because it can be used to
detect a heart attack at the point of
care and on the left is data published
by Phillips in 209 article on lab on
chip and they use this device to measure
cardiaca troponin CTN is cut it to
opponent and this is a signal versus
concentration and you can see that they
can detect the signal down to about one
pickle molar or about the 24 picogram
per milliliter so this is very high
sensitive on our sensor and for a
healthy person normally the cottage
proponent lover should be very very low
but if there's a blood clot of some sort
in the utter artery of heart he has
shown number one the downstream heart
vessels will be cut off blood supply and
depleted of nutritions and so the
tissues will muscles will start to die
and that those processes will generate
the cottage to opponent and there was
not circulating blood stream elsewhere
and so if you have a
sensitive about sensor to detect the
onset and the increase of cardiac
troponin then that's a you can detect a
heart attack early in the save lives and
I hope that in the future this puppy
this kind of device will be become a
wearable device on people who need it
another technology I wanted to talk
about is well electronica medicine and
this is a home loan technology in
professor ADA prunes lab at the Stanford
electrons in a department this is a
device shown at top and blue lines are
no systems in human body and if you
insert this device at the right spot
light and nerve of the brain basically
you can reduce the symptom or prevent
even things like a up lopsy or
depression just by giving a tiny
electrical post at the right nerve spot
and this is a very exciting area and you
I'm sure you will hear more about this
technology fund Stanfill and many other
research organizations so this brings me
to my last slide for my portion of the
presentation we are developing tiny bow
sensors and the foul imaging tools which
was supposed to be professor Adam those
orders talk on but that you will
probably find him elsewhere in the
future on all these technologists will
allow us to achieve so-called
data-driven diagnostics and a medicine
and that will of
translate into better diagnosis more
effective therapy and new electronic
electronic medicine in addition to 20
drugs etc and that will allow us to
really make technology work for
humankind that's our goal and and we use
technology study the entire human body
excels in human body proteins antibodies
DNA's rnase some of which I touched in
previous slides and i hope that i will
meet you on internet again in the future
thank you son great let's get into some
of the questions so the one question is
of any power sensors to detect the
stroke brain attack or heart attack so
the troponin or cardiac troponin which I
talk about is a biomarker for heart
attack and so obviously the sensor from
Philips is designed to detect heart
attack and in many other technologies
for stroke which happens in brain
unfortunately there's no such biomarker
equipment to see Troy cardiac troponin
or CTN and but the many people working
on that and and in the near future I
think such technology will be available
these senses fda-approved on the in vivo
power sensor from dr. Seuss lab is a not
FDA approved as you record so far the
technology has only been applied to
animal because it's a required
chemo drug injection and you really
can't do this kind of test very easily
in human but they are moving to human
and hopefully in the future that it will
be FDA approved and the Philips opto
magnetic power sensors i believe is
approved in europe but it will probably
be improving in us in the future if
things go well so the next questions
where r would these new technology
available on marketing the opto magnetic
the power sensor from famous is
available from on market the other
technologies i mentioned all in the
research development stage they are not
a publicly available on market at at
this point so the next questions that i
mentioned i hope the philips optimum
mega power sensor will be made of
wearable that's a a impromptu comment i
do not know for sure if Phillips is
working on a wearable version of that
device but i think that's a comment from
application pool perspective because you
know we often hear stories like someone
when jogging and got a heart attack in
the middle of the jogging and by the
time it was discovered was too late to
be saved and so if we have a wearable
device like Apple watch like a fit a bit
and it could measure the tiny amount of
troponin in blood stream on them you
know before jogging or in the beginning
of
logging is not to see these upper
regulation of markers and you can or
instead of go for a long jog you jog
around the hospital or just canceled the
chocolate that day and watch for your
other vital signs so I think that kind
of device will be much more powerful
than just a device to measure your heart
rate or your body temperature okay so
the next the question is that the harm
the possible harm of using mobile phones
and other eam devices and also the about
degradable sensors as you know there's
no free lunch so in health care whenever
we introduce a new drug or new device to
various degree there are some cons to
balance out the pros and that's where
you know the engineers and the
researchers coming we have to understand
pros and cons of ever new technology and
then we can deploy them intelligently
and so for particle degradable senses we
have to make sure you know what's it
what's the degree of the side effects
and so if there's a certain side effects
we probably should not marketer those
device to everyone if you are reasonably
healthy you probably shouldn't wear this
you know troponin wearable device um but
if you have some history of heart
attacks and you have very high level of
class jos-na you
high risks of heart attack then you
probably should expand the money to buy
this wearable uh detective ice or in the
future in unity stroke sensors okay the
next question is could you speak to the
economics of nano census to imagine
emerging markets and also what's the
coefficient of variation for these
senses okay emerging markets is a bigger
market even though they are emerging for
a lot of biosensors and unfortunately
relative to the OECD countries or
advanced countries people have less
purchasing power so all these new
technologies being developed would have
a harder time to be economically
successful in emerging markets so of
cancer test which is / will allow the
developer and the companies to make a
profit in u.s. not necessary in China
India so that's a reality of anyone
who's planning to develop new
technologies in healthcare area in terms
of coefficient of variations that's a
very loaded a question and I really
can't ask about them for all the
technologies but just two examples the
next shift device for my own lab which I
talk about data has a coefficient of
variation of you know ten percent to
fifty percent so it's a quite a variable
so it's a really not a good device for
just count how many CDC's which are
there in each
because the technology is not really
precise in terms of counting CDC's but
it's a very good at technology for
catching CDC's in the study what kind of
mutation happened in cancer so for one
mutation like a EGFR mutation on in lung
cancer and the certain so-called
targeted drugs can work very well for
that mutated cancer cell so in that a
particular application that the device
is very very useful in spite of large
coefficient variation now for the opto
magnetic power sensors from Phillips the
coefficient variation I think it showed
in while the standard curves and those
devices I think it can be made to have
CBS below twenty percent and the meat of
FDA requirements in the future thank you
very much for all of your time today an
effort this is wonderful i learned a
couple of new things so i'm very excited
about this i didn't know the technology
you know we always think technology is
advancing too quickly but these are some
great advancements for more information
on any of the online graduate courses
please check out SCPD stanford.edu and
you can get more information on
enrollment requirements and course
information as far as when they'll be
offered again thank you very much allow
me to thank you stacy for hosting me
this is very exciting a seminar for
myself and all i want to thank everyone
without a ying and asking so many great
questions
you